量子コンピューティングの実践へようこそ、Olivia Lanだ。今日のエピソード3では、
ユーティリティスケールでのqaoaの実験に焦点を当てていく。最初から見てくれてた人は、
IBM Quantumのハードウェア、Qiskitパターンのフレームワーク、最新の誤り緩和技術を
研究者や開発者がどう使って量子circuitをスケールアップするかを解説してきたのを見てきたはずだ。このすべての
コンテキストを伝えて、どの方向に向かっているかを示すことが本当に重要だと思ってた。でも今はもうこれ以上待つ理由はない。この情報をすべて
実際に動かすところを見てもらおう。始める前にいくつか注意点がある。すべてQiskitの
パターンのフレームワークに従って進めていく。順番にステップを踏んでいく。まず1つ目が問題のマッピング、2つ目がcircuitの最適化、3つ目が
Primitivesを使った実行、4つ目が後処理、つまり結果の分析だ。かなり小さな例から始める
ので、みんながこれらのステップとその目的をうまく理解できるはずだ。それから、よく似てるけどもっと
大きな例を見ていく。問題を100 qubitレベルまでどうスケールアップするかを示すためだ。みんなに
この講義の後に前に進んで、その問題を独自に実行できるよう、すべてのツールを渡す。最後に、これは
コードのウォークスルーにはならない。どれだけ頑張っても、進捗とともにコードは古くなって非推奨になっていく。だから
このビデオを公開から1年後に見てるとしたら、時間とともに少し変わるかもしれない構文にこだわってほしくない。その代わりに、これは
ロジックと問題文についての詳細な議論になる。ただし、これに対応するノートブックチュートリアルが
この動画と一緒にある。下の概要欄にリンクが貼ってある。コードを見ながら進めるか、視聴後に参照して
自分で実行することで、最高の学習体験が得られる。簡単なリマインダーとして、
すべての計算問題が量子コンピューティングに適しているわけじゃない。簡単な問題や単純な計算はこの
技術を活用する必要がない。古典コンピュータがすでに十分に解けるからだ。2024年時点で、
最も楽観的に探求できる3つのドメインはこれらだ。自然のシミュレーション、複雑な
構造を持つデータの処理、そして最後に最適化だ。最適化問題は、計算上最も難しい
問題の一部で、効率的に解くのが大変だ。最適化問題では、与えられたコスト関数に対して最大値または最小値を
探すことになる。しかし、関心のある多くの問題では、この極値を見つけることが問題のサイズに対して指数関数的に
難しくなっていく。だからこそ計算が非常に難しくなる。例えば、
国中の最適な飛行ルートや配送ルートを計算するのがいかに難しいか想像できるだろう。この講義では
Max cutと呼ばれる特定の最適化問題を探求していく。これを量子
アルゴリズム、量子近似最適化アルゴリズム（qaoa）を使って解く。Max cut問題とは何か。
最大カット問題はグラフ上で定義された組み合わせ最適化問題の一種で、目標は
グラフの頂点を2つのサブセットに分割して、2つのサブセット間のエッジの数が
最大になるようにすることだ。例えば、このグラフでは各ノードがこのように繋がっていて、Max cutはこのギザギザの
線で示されていて、ノードを紫のグループとグレーのグループに分けている。できるだけ多くの
エッジを横切る方法は、このグラフで5本のエッジを切ることだ。このグラフはとても小さいので、
紙の上や頭の中でいくつかの可能なカットを試して、5が最良の選択肢だと
見つけ出すのは難しくない。でもノード数が2倍、3倍になったら素早く、これを手でやるのは不可能になる。
そしてある数を超えると、スーパーコンピュータでさえ最良の答えを確実に返すのに苦労するほど難しくなる。なぜなら
カットの最大数がノード数に対して指数関数的にスケールするからだ。これは少し抽象的に見えるかもしれないが、
Max cut問題に落とし込める現実世界の問題は多い。金融における不正検出、グラフ
クラスタリング、ネットワーク設計、VLSIデザイン、そしてソーシャルメディア分析もある。
ソーシャルメディアの例は特に理解しやすい。ソーシャルメディアプラットフォーム上で、できるだけ多くの
他のユーザーとの接続を持つ個人のグループを見つけたいとしよう。パワーユーザーや
グループで最も影響力を持つ人を特定するためだ。企業は実際にこれをかなり頻繁に試みている。最後にもう1点、Max cutはしばしば
より大きな問題のサブルーティンになっている。だから実際のアプリケーションを定義しているわけじゃなくて、裏で使われていることがある。
素朴に思うよりずっと一般的なんだ。さあ、始める時が来た。
最初のステップはグラフを作ることだ。rustWorksというPythonパッケージをインポートしてこれができる。
作業するノード数をnという数で指定し、グラフGにノードを追加していく。
エッジも描く必要がある。ここでは手動でこのように配列にリストアップする。エッジの
重みを示す最後の数字、つまり指定された2つのノードがどれだけ強く繋がっているかを指定する。ここでは
すべての重みを1にするが、後で重みをいじって解がどう変わるか楽しんでみてもいい。
重みが何を意味するか感じ取るために、ソーシャルメディアの例に戻ろう。
この重みを、ある人が別の人にどれだけ影響力を持つかとして考えられる。配偶者や親戚との繋がりは
単なる知人よりも高い重みが与えられるだろう。次にグラフを描こう。
添付のチュートリアルで適切な構文を示す。まず考える前に、この問題を
量子circuitにどうマッピングするか。Max cut問題がどのように最適化
問題になるかについてコンテキストを作ろう。まず関数f(x)の最小化を考えることから始める。入力xはn
次元のベクトルで、その成分はグラフの各ノードに対応している。この関数を今後
コスト関数と呼ぶ。次に、これらの各成分をゼロまたは
1に制約する必要がある。ここではカットのどちら側にあるかを意味する。関数を
ノードのペアxiとxjとして書ける。これは対応するエッジがカットにあるかどうかを示す。つまり量 xi + xj
- xi * xj がエッジがカットにあるかどうかを識別する。この量が
1に等しければ、エッジがカットにあることを意味する。そうでなければ0でエッジはない。
カットにある最大のエッジ数を見つける問題は、この関数を最大化することとして定式化できる。次に実際に
この関数にグローバルなマイナス符号を付けて、新しい問題をこの関数の最小値を見つけることと等価にする。
代わりに、この場合のf(x)の最小値はcutによって横断されるエッジの数が
最大となるときだ。この問題を最小化問題として定式化するのは、後でエネルギーに対応させるためだ
最小化問題、つまり基底状態を求めることに変換できるからで、これは量子コンピュータが本来非常に得意とすることだ
でも覚えておいてほしいのは、ここにはまだQuantum Computingに関連するものは何もないということだ。この問題を
量子コンピュータが理解できる形に再定式化する必要がある。さあ、本格的に作業を始める準備ができた。
最初のステップは問題をQuantum circuitにマッピングすることだ。グラフから
Quantum circuitにどうやって変換するのか、すぐには分からないかもしれないが、ゆっくり進めていこう。
このMax cut問題をqaoaを使って解こうとしている。qaoaアルゴリズムでは最終的にoperatorを持ちたい
ハミルトニアンで、問題のコスト関数を表現するのに使う。そしてパラメータ化された
circuit、anotまたは試行状態を使って、教育的な推測や候補となる量子状態を表現する
これらの候補状態からサンプリングして評価することができる
コスト関数を使って。この場合コスト関数はf(x)だが、これを
量子コンピュータにネイティブな形で表現する必要がある。そのために一連の数学的
変換を活用してf(x)をエネルギー関数、つまりハミルトニアンとして表現する。このプロセスの
最初のステップは、f(x)の最小化問題を二値二次非制約最適化
問題、略してCuboとして表現することだ。Cuboはこれらの組み合わせ最適化問題を定式化する一般的な方法だ
ここでQはN×Nの実数行列であり、Nは
グラフのノード数に対応する。この例では5で、Xは最初の
定式化と同じ二値変数のベクトルだ。qaoaアルゴリズムを効果的に実行するには、最適化問題を
ハミルトニアンで表現する必要がある。これはシステムの全エネルギーを表す数学的operatorだ。具体的には
コスト関数ハミルトニアンを作りたい。その基底状態エネルギーまたは最小固有値が
グラフg上の最大カット数を符号化する関数の最小値に対応するものだ。このハミルトニアンが
できたら、最適化問題を解くためにすることは、量子コンピュータ上でハミルトニアンの基底状態を準備することだ。その後
この状態からサンプリングすれば、高い確率でf(x)の最小化の解が得られる。実は
ラッキーなことに、Cubo問題は非常に密接に関連していて、実際には計算的に等価だ
物理学で最も有名で広く使われているハミルトニアンの一つ、イジングハミルトニアンと。Cubo問題を
このイジングハミルトニアンとして書くために実際に必要なのは、単純な変数変換だけだ。
ブール変数の0と1からスピン変数のマイナス1と1に変換するためだ。このステップは
簡単だ。詳細は添付ノートブックの付録に示している。興味のある人は参照してほしい。最終的にこのCuboの
最小化はこの式の最小化と同じだ。少し書き直すと
コスト関数ハミルトニアンが得られる。式の最小値は基底状態を表し、Z
はパウリoperatorになり、Bは実数のスカラー係数だ。ハミルトニアンが
得られたので、2つの局所ZZパウリoperatorで書き直すことができる。これはQuantum circuitで
2つのcubic gateに簡単に変換できる。詳細は関連ノートブックを参照してほしいが、出力は
このコード行で得られる。この例では
6つのオブジェクトまたはパウリ文字列がある。各々がグラフのエッジを表すからだ。文字列の長さはノード数と一致し
i i i ZZは5つのノードを表す。文字列は
エッジに関係するノードのインデックス以外はすべて単位行列で構成され、Z項を持つ。Qiskitでは
qubitを表すbit文字列は逆順でインデックスされる。例えばノード0と1の間のエッジは
I I I ZZとして符号化される。ハミルトニアンをパウリで表現できたので、
Quantum circuitを構築する準備ができた。このQuantum circuitは量子コンピュータから良い解をサンプリングするのに役立つ。qaoaアルゴリズムは
断熱定理からインスパイアされている。断熱定理は、時間依存ハミルトニアンの基底状態から始めると
ハミルトニアンが十分ゆっくり進化し十分な時間があれば、最終状態は最終ハミルトニアンの基底状態になるというものだ
qaoaは量子断熱アルゴリズムの離散トロッター版として考えることができ
各トロッターステップはレイヤーを表す。これをPと呼ぶ。だから
一つの状態から別の状態へ進化させる代わりに、Pの各レイヤーでコスト
関数ハミルトニアンとmixerハミルトニアンと呼ばれるものを交互に切り替える。これについてはすぐ後で詳しく話すが、伝えたい点は
qaoaは量子断熱アルゴリズムより速いという利点があるが、近似的な
解を返すことで最適解ではない。レイヤー数が無限大に近づく極限ではqaoaは断熱的な
場合に収束するが、もちろんこれは計算コストが非常に高い。Quantum circuitを作るために
交互operatorを適用する。ここではgammaとbetaでパラメータ化され、
時間発展の離散化を表す。qaoaのcircuitの3つの主要部分は
1つ目がグレーで示された初期試行状態で、断熱的な
進化の基底状態から生成され、すべてのqubitにHadamard gateを適用して作られる。2つ目が
すでに持っている濃い紫で示されたコスト関数の発展。3つ目はmixer
ハミルトニアンの下での発展で、薄い紫で示されており、まだ議論していない。開始ハミルトニアンは
mixerと呼ばれる。その基底状態が関心のある全ビット文字列の重ね合わせだからだ
つまり最初にすべての可能な解の混合を強制する。mixer ハミルトニアンはグラフの各ノードに対するパウリX
operationsの単純な和だ。Qiskitでは望めばカスタムmixer operatorを使うことができるが
この場合は標準的なものを使う。こうしてQiskitを使えば多くの作業が
省かれ、mixer ハミルトニアンと開始状態の導出が簡単になる。唯一やるべき作業は
コスト関数を見つけることだ。これらのoperatorの各反復はレイヤーと呼ばれる。これらのレイヤーは
前述のとおりシステムの時間発展を離散化したもので、交互のパターンは
Trotter分解から来ており、一般的に非可換行列の指数関数を近似する。レイヤーや
ステップを増やすほど連続時間発展に近づく。つまり理論上は結果の精度が高くなる
わけだが、この例ではまず2層でサンプリングを始める。コスト関数のハミルトニアンも
mixerもパラメータ化されていることを忘れるな。gammaとの最適値をまだ決める必要がある
beta。情報量が多かったのはわかってる。こういう数式を初めて見る場合はとっつきにくいかもしれない。でも幸いなことに、Qiskitの素晴らしい点のひとつは
今説明した多くのことが、ユーザーの大きな負担なく自動的にできるということだ。何が
裏で起きているかを理解しておくのは大事で、特に実験規模が大きくなったときにそうだ。でもこの作業を毎回すべて
手動でやる必要はない。これで問題をQuantum circuitにマッピングできた。少し手間がかかったが
やればやるほど簡単になってくるし直感的にもなる。次のステップ2に進む準備ができた
circuitをハードウェア向けに最適化する。今作ったcircuitはシンプルに見えるし
直感的な理解を積み上げるには役立つが、quantum chipはこの抽象化された
ブロックを理解できない。ハードウェアにネイティブな1つまたは2つのqubit gateの列に変換する必要がある
ネイティブというのは、qubit上で直接実行できる形にリファクタリングされるということだ。そういったcircuitは
backendの命令セットアーキテクチャ（ISA）で書かれていると言われる。ISA circuitと略されることもある
Qiskit SDKのtranspilerモジュールは、一連のtranspilationパスを提供しており
幅広いcircuit変換が可能だ。circuitが目的に合わせて最適化されていることを確認したい
前回のレッスンで学んだように、transpilationのプロセスにはいくつかのステップがある。circuitの
qubit（つまり決定変数）をデバイス上の物理qubitにマッピングする。circuitの命令を
backendが実際に理解できるハードウェアネイティブな命令に展開する。直接相互作用する
circuit内のqubitを、隣接する物理qubitにルーティングする
そしていつものように、詳細はドキュメントで確認できる
サイト。次は重要なステップで、circuitをどのbackendで実行するか選ぶ。実はこれを
transpilationステップの前にやる必要がある。transpilerはプロセッサごとに異なる最適化をするからだ。これもまた
Qiskitがこのステージの多くを自動化できることが重要な理由だ。circuitを手動で最適化したくはないだろう
手動でも可能だが、時間がかかるし面倒だ。それをやった後で実際には
別のプロパティを持つ別のプロセッサで実行したいと気づいたら、また全部やり直しになる
選んだbackendをtranspiler関数に渡して、最適化レベルの指定を忘れるな
今回は最適化レベル3を選んだ。これは最高で最も徹底的な最適化
レベルだ。ステップ2はこれで終わり。circuitは自動的にtranspileされた。ここに描いたのは
1つまたは2つのqubit gateにどう変換されたかを見せるためだ。ではステップ3に進む
Qiskit Primitivesでcircuitを実行する。ここまででcircuitをtranspileし、パラメータgammaと
betaはそのままにしてある。ただし実際にcircuitを実行するにはこれらのパラメータの値を指定しなければならない。QAOAの
ワークフローでは、最適なQAOAパラメータは反復最適化ループで見つける。一連のcircuit
評価を実行し、古典的なOptimizerを使って最適なbetaとgammaのパラメータを探す。でもまず
初期値が必要なので、Gamma 1、gamma 2、beta 1、beta 2の初期推定値としてPi / 2とPiを
それぞれ設定した。gammaとbetaのより良い解を見つけるためにoptimizerを使うことも覚えておいてほしい
今は2層だけ計算しているからこれで十分だ。でも精度の高いQAOA circuitを作るなら
より多くの層を含めることになり、各sequential
layerに対して最適化されたgammaとbetaが必要になる。少し立ち止まって、Primitivesの選択肢を思い出してほしい。estimatorと
samplerがある。このタイプのジョブにはどちらを使うと思う？実はどちらを選んでも
正解だ。estimatorとsamplerの両方を使う。初期最適化
ループにはestimatorが必要で、最終的な解の読み出しにはsamplerを使う
では、アルゴリズムを実行する準備がほぼできた。でも手短に、ジョブの送信には
様々な方法があることを覚えておくのが大事だ。それをexecution modesと呼ぶ。まずjob modeはシングルの
estimatorまたはsamplerへのリクエストで、context managerなしで行う。circuitと入力はprimitive
unified blocks（PUB）としてパッケージ化され、quantum
computer上の実行タスクとして送信される。batch modeは、大量の
独立したジョブで構成される実験を効率的に実行するためのマルチジョブマネージャーだ。batch modeを使って複数のprimitive jobを同時に送信する。session modeはマルチジョブの
ワークロードを実行するための専用ウィンドウだ。プレミアムユーザーが変分アルゴリズムをより
予測可能な方法で試したり、スタックの並列性を活かして複数の実験を同時に実行したりできる
反復的なワークフローや専用アクセスが必要な実験にはsessionを使う。QAOA実験には
アクセスできるなら、sessionを選ぶのが良い。betaの異なる値に対して複数のcircuitを試す必要があるから
gammaもそうだ。最適化問題に戻ろう。コスト関数のハミルトニアンHCはすでに
定義してある。全体のワークフローはこうだ。QAOAの
アルゴリズムはqubitを重ね合わせ状態に初期化することから始まり、P層でUNOTを適用する
gammaとbetaパラメータを初期化し、estimator primitiveを使ってcircuitを実行する。expectation値を計算したら
CobaというsciPy Optimizerを使う。Coba
はコスト関数をQPUの外部で古典的に最適化する。gammaとbetaの値が更新されたら
繰り返す。全体のコスト関数が収束して最低値に達するまでこれを続ける
そしてこの低コスト値に対応するgammaとbetaの値を選んで、最後にcircuitをもう一度実行する
今度はsamplerを使う。これがCoba Optimizerを初期推定値で実行した結果だ。ここで
コスト関数の値が反復を重ねるにつれて最初は少し不安定で上下するが、
その後低い値に落ち着く。コスト最小に対応する最後のgammaとbetaの値を使って、
circuit を最後にもう一度実行し、最大カットを与えるbit stringをサンプリングする。
gammaとbetaの最適化された値を使って、最良の
bit stringをsamplerで見つけるためcircuitを最後にもう一度実行する。ここで使用している具体的な値を示したが、自分で試すときや
同じチュートリアルノートブックを再実行するだけでも、これらの値は少し変わる可能性がある。では
最適化されたcircuitをこれらの値で実行し、Max cutの候補解を見つける。もし
sessionsを使っていたとしても、最後のジョブを一つ実行するだけなのでもはや不要だ。いよいよ
後処理ステージを見て最終解を求める。まず全ての
ノードの組み合わせをbit stringに変換してヒストグラムとして描画する。すぐに分かるのが、
実行した結果、他のどの解よりも確率の高い4つの解が紫でハイライトされて見つかったことだ。
最も確率が高いbit stringの解は0101だ。qubitの順序に注意してほしい。
プロットでは順序が逆になっている。最も確率の高い解を見ると、ノード0と3がひとまとめになっていて、
同様にノード1、2、4もひとまとめになっている。最も確率の高い
bit stringをグラフとして描画できる。bit stringはノード番号に単純に対応していて、グループ分けに含まれるかどうかは
1でマークされているか0でマークされているかで分かる。カットを描くと、目で見て
最良のカットのおおよその線が分かる。これは5つのノード全ての理想的なグループ分けを表していて、ここに描いている。一つ
ここで時間をかけて議論したいのは、正しい解が一意ではないという事実だ。
このグラフの対称性から、正しい解は複数存在する。ノード0と3が
カットの内側にある代わりに、ノード2と4が含まれていてもよく、カットを回転させるだけでいいのが分かる。
これらの新しい点を含めるようにカットを回転させた。カット数5という解は変わらない。
ヒストグラムと最も確率の高い4つの解をもう一度見てみよう。最後の2つの解は
今描いたものと同じで、どちらも等しく正しい。だがそれだけじゃない。全ての
正しい解の色を反転させることもできる。この場合はノードをカットの内側と外側として考える。
前のスライドで2つのユニークな正しい解を特定したが、実はそれぞれの逆に対応するさらに2つの解がある。
残りの2つの解を描いたここを見ると、色を反転させただけなのが分かる。
唯一の問題は、アルゴリズムが実際にはこの4番目の最後の解を
上位4つの最も確率の高い答えとして見つけたり特定したりしなかったことだ。5番目だった。アルゴリズムが特定した4番目の解は
実際には不正確で、描いてみると、その解はカット数が4しかなく、他は
5つあるので4は明らかに5より少なく、明らかに間違いだ。ここでのポイントは、
これは近似アルゴリズムだということだ。絶対ではなく、100%正しいわけではない。解の妥当性を確認するために
自分の知識と理解を活用する必要がある。このエラーは
いくつかの場所から生じる可能性があることを強調しておく価値がある。アルゴリズム自体の近似的な性質と、採用した
レイヤー数が少ないことが原因かもしれない。有限サンプリングエラーの可能性もあって、実験のshots数を増やせば低減できる。
あるいは読み出しエラーかもしれない。4番目の本当の解はわずか1
bitずれているだけだから。これらの可能性を全て指摘している理由は、quantum Computingの
practitionerとして完全になるためにはこれが必要だからだ。ハードウェアの性能と、それが
特定の種類のエラーにどう影響するか、そしてそれをどう補正するかを理解する必要がある。ただし、
32個のbit stringの解があって、4つの本当の解がトップ5に含まれていたことを忘れないでほしい。
そして2つのレイヤーだけでこれを見つけた。一般的に、最良の
Max cutを毎回見つける可能性を高めたければ、レイヤーの深さを増やす。これにはいくつかの微妙な点があるが、それは後の
エピソードで扱う。では自分でこれを試してもらうが、今度は100
qubitを使う。100 qubitのグラフを描くと、max cutがどこにあるか簡単には分からず、目で見て特定することすら不可能なのが分かる。
単純に可能性が多すぎて手で選び出せない。だが
qoaを使ってこの問題を解くことは十分可能で、5
qubitで使ったのと全く同じワークフローに従える。これから一人でやってもらおうとしているが、その前に
まとめよう。qaoa jobの6つのステップは以下の通りだ。1つ目は
コストハミルトニアンを定義すること。その基底状態が最適化問題の解をエンコードするようにする。2つ目は
mixerハミルトニアンを定義すること。3つ目は指数化された
ハミルトニアンに対応するoperatorを構築すること。4つ目はcircuitを構築すること。mixerの初期基底状態と、コスト関数とmixer Hamiltonianの発展の
交互の繰り返しレイヤーで構成される。5つ目は初期状態を準備して
古典的なコンピューティング技術を使ってパラメータを最適化すること。6つ目はcircuitを実行して出力bit stringを測定し
最も確率の高い解を探すことだ。ここでいくつか注記しておく。
5 qubitの例では最適化レベル3を使ったが、それは必ずしも必要ではなかったかもしれない。5
qubitはcircuitの深さがかなり浅かったため、より低い最適化レベルでも正しい答えがほとんどの場合返ってくる可能性がある。
だが100 qubitで大きなcircuitの深さの場合、正しい答えを見つけるには最高レベルの
最適化がほぼ確実に必要だ。また、典型的なutility
スケールのワークフローで最も難しい部分の一つはマッピングステージで、IBMのheavy hex topologyに対応するグラフを見つけることだ。
ゼロからこの作業をするなら、間違いなくそこに多くの時間を費やすことになる。今回はこの部分は
この演習の主なポイントではないので、用意してある。
ただし、練習が必要なことであり、大規模なジョブの実行は常に簡単というわけではないことを念頭に置いてほしい。これについては
エピソード4でさらに詳しく説明するが、最終的なcircuitは5 qubitで動かしたcircuitよりずっと複雑に見えるはずだ
でも一方で、このcircuitを見てgateの数を確認して、それを実際の
量子プロセッサで動かせる能力があると知ることは、かなり
印象的だと思う。これが俺の最終的な解答で、このアルゴリズムがこれらを
ノードを2つのグループに分類できることが分かる。二つの集合から最大カットを最もうまく分割する方法を識別しているとされている
max cutラインに移行するのは自明で、ノードを結ぶ線に沿って色が変わる場所が
max cutラインを引くべき場所を示している。実行したところ、達成できたmax cutの値は
84だった。自分でも試してコメントで同じような結果が出たか教えてくれ。3層か4層試してみて、
ノード間の重みを変えて結果がどう変わるか確認してほしい。qaoaで実行できる面白い実験が
たくさんある。ただ覚えておいてほしいのは、俺が見つけた解が必ずしも最善の
解だとは保証されていないということだ。良い解だとは分かっているが、面白みとして俺を超えられるか挑戦してみてくれ。
84より良いものが出せるか確認してほしい。まとめると、qaoaは非常にダイナミックな
アルゴリズムで、ヒューリスティクスもたくさんあり、まだ探求すべきことが多い。最適化の分野全般について新しいことを
学ぶ余地がたくさんある。最近、最適化の分野で多くの研究が行われていて、
qaoaや最適化に関してオンラインで最近公開されたarXivの論文がそれを証明している。そして
本当に面白いのは、これらの論文がすべて理論論文というわけではなくなってきたことだ。理論家たちは長年
qaoaを研究してきたが、今では実験家たちも参加し始めている。なぜならようやくハードウェアが
整ってきたからだ。IBMのプロセッサのような、これらの実験の多くを実行できるものが出てきた。想像の世界から
現実の世界へと移行しているんだ。それはとてもエキサイティングだ。まだやるべき仕事は多くあるし、
対処法を考えないといけないエラーもたくさんある。でも着実に進歩していて、これを視聴している
あなたが、ここまで見てくれたなら、自分でこれらの実験を実行できる。ぜひ自分の
100 qubitの実験を実行してどうだったか教えてくれ。チュートリアルに沿って進めれば大丈夫だ。もし
質問があったり行き詰まっても心配しないでくれ。みんな最初は同じ気持ちだったし、同じ疑問を持っていた
ベストを尽くして、出てきた疑問を教えてくれ。また次回お会いしよう
[Music]